alright guys I did receive my order
today for the black V Cube collection
which includes the V cube 5 6 & 7 as
many of you have seen my white B cube 7
core piece did fracture off after I
dropped it on the floor and I spoke with
the V Cube customer service and did some
of them a video of the broken tube
however due to the circumstances they
said they would not replace my core I
had the cube for a while
about 8 months and they did not believe
the core was defective so I did crazy
glue the piece back on the core piece
which fractured off however when I went
to take apart the cube to lubricate it
so it would turn smoother and I put it
back together the core piece fractured
back off so I didn't expect it to hold
but either way it was solving pretty
well for a little while so eventually
after a few messages back and forth I
took responsibility for the fracture
since I did drop it on the floor causing
it to break so I asked if I could
purchase a new core along with the black
V Cube collection and they accepted that
offer so the V Cube 7 core cost about 5
euros or about 6.50 cents and the black
collection was around 130 dollars I
believe with the shipping so they did
lower the prices for all of the cubes
and also the collection which is why I
decided to buy the black collection now
so the or the order itself was placed
over a week ago but it took around four
days for me to actually get the package
once it was shipped I'm not going to
take the cubes out of the box on video
but I will cut them out of the plastic
just so you can see what they look like
before they're removed just the
packaging and everything like that so I
have previously reviewed the entire
white V Cube collection on video however
however I'll also give a short first
impression review of the black cubes as
well alright so I just opened the V cube
black collection box and I did notice
the slight change in how the boxes are
wrapped they used to be wrapped in a
sort of cellophane plastic now they have
a harder plastic and the it's like a
sleeve plastic that this whole bar
is wrapped in and the box just slides
out sort of like that so this is the
black V Cube v as you can see it does
have white stickers where the the white
V Cube the white plastic V Cube has the
black stickers instead so I also did get
the V Cube seven core that they sent me
and as you can see they didn't put the
the center caps on but that's fine
because I'm just going to take him off
the the pieces that I have the other V
cubed core is broken anyway so it
doesn't really matter but there's my new
v-cube seven white core so hopefully
I'll have my V Cube seven the white V
Cube seven assembled pretty soon and
ready to use so what I'm going to do now
I'm just gonna try to test out the three
cubes and see how well they spin and I
will give a short first impression
review of how I think the black of the
cubes compared to the white V cubes
alright so once you take the cubes out
of the package you will notice that they
come with a small little pamphlet and
this panel just gives a little bit of
background information to their inventor
mister panayotis ver does and it does
also give some information on the cube
itself that you have purchased so it
does tell about the permutations and how
many pieces the cube consists of one
thing I also noticed about the black V
Cube set when I got it was that they did
have a little bit of lubrication to them
especially the V Cube six when you pick
them up the and you play around with a
little bit you will notice that there is
a little bit of a greasy feel to it it's
really noticeable on the V Cube six but
not so much on the 5 and the 7 so the V
Cube 5 overall is a little bit rigid out
of the box but once you solve it a few
times you'll notice that it will loosen
up a great amount so the outside layers
do have a little bit of a clicky feel
but it does not really interfere with
speed solving
at all it still allows you to turn it
just about as fast as you want to layers
the two outside layers together spin
extremely smooth although my white cube
is looser at the moment it's only
because I've had it for longer and I
actually lubricated it and it's been
broken in a lot as you could see the
stickers on my white vq5 have peeled
somewhat on the new cubes I did notice
that the cubes do have sort of a sort of
like a mesh in them it almost looks like
a checkerboard I did draw it here
because I knew it wouldn't be visible on
camera so if you do take a look at this
diagram I do kind of looks like a like a
checkerboard almost has like these
little dots in it it's not really
visible on the actual cubes through the
camera but there is some sort of mesh
and I believe it does hold the stickers
a little bit better hopefully so they
don't fall apart as much as the I guess
the older models did I take it these are
just newer stickers for either the black
or the white cubes so I do think that
will help
hopefully in keeping the stickers more
intact but overall the vq5 is a great
key the crust corners amazingly
so overall the vq5 is an amazing cube
and I would say it is the best 5x5 cube
on the market right now so the viewcube
six also came with the small little
pamphlet and it does mention that it has
the click mechanism and that you should
hear a click before making the next move
also about the middle layers if you
don't hear the click then the cube will
lock up so that is one problem that the
V cube 6 has and they do note that so
when I first picked up the black v cube
6 I noticed that it was pretty greasy
actually you feel like your hands are
almost wet so I did notice that about
the cube it does have a clicking
mechanism but overall I would say that
the lubrication that it has does help it
out a little bit I believe it's some
sort of silicone lubricant and it does
have the kind of smell that silicone has
so it might have some sort of silicone
in it overall you know is what I
expected it to be it's it's a pretty
good speed cube however I think I might
go on and modify it I'm considering it
since I would like to solve it as fast
as possible so the clicking mechanism
mechanism is more noticeable when you're
turning all three layers not so much
with the outer ones the pieces do pop
the center edge pieces just like the six
by the white V cube six they do pop it
can cut corners somewhat but I wouldn't
try anything too major because the
pieces do pop out relatively easy while
your speed solving so you have to be
careful and you have to have a little
bit of control over the cube but overall
I do like the V cube six the black V
Cube six I think after a little bit of
braking and possibly modification this
cube can be a great cube definitely
alright so the V cube seven out of the
box is a little bit rigid but after a
few solves it does become notice of
we loser especially the outer layers
they turn a lot smoother than the inner
layers do but overall all the layers
turn pretty smoothly there's no clicking
in the v-cube 7 it is lubricated already
so it does help a little bit with the
process of breaking it in and helping it
to spin a little bit so the cube does
cut corners really well it is a little
bit harder I feel to align the layers
right now I think because the cube
hasn't been broken in and it is a little
bit rigid overall the v-cube 70 is a
great cube and I did notice actually you
know I said that thing about the sticker
is having that mesh in it well I did
notice that some of the stickers are
already peeling and I've only solved it
a few times so it does have that little
almost like it's being ripped so it is
ripping a little bit so I'm not sure if
that mesh will truly help but we'll see
after a few more songs but comparable it
is definitely comparable to my white V
cube 7 which I did reassemble and as you
could see the cube is very very rigid so
I don't know if I think the core is
pretty tight I'm gonna have to break the
cube in and I did notice that the center
pieces do pop out I believe that is
because it is so tight and I need to you
know let it become a little bit looser
so it goes the center piece there goes
another one so overall you know I'm
pretty happy that I got a new core but
you know my cube is a lot tighter now so
I'm gonna have to do some breaking in
all right so of the 3 cubes for the
black collection I'm gonna have to say
that the vq5 is my favorite followed by
the V cube 7 and then the V cube 6 it is
a little bit rigid and I do think if I
modified it it would help out a little
bit my white V cube 6 is definitely
looser I did sand down some parts on the
inside to hopefully help it turn better
and it does turn pretty well but it does
still have that locking problem so this
is definitely gonna need some adjustment
and I am planning on doing an advanced
education tutorial for the 5x5 cube to
help you guys get a little bit faster
with the
pairing which does take up the most time
when you're solving the vq5 one more
thing I did notice that some of the
bubbles were present in the stickers and
I don't know if that's going to affect
how it peels but yeah there are quite a
few of them in the cube so that's the
review and definitely be sure to keep an
eye out for that advanced edge parent
tutorial for the 5x5 thanks for watching